la Tour Eiffel paraît de bleu et de
jaune les couleurs du drapeau ukrainien
en signe de solidarité un témoignage
appuyé sur Twitter par le président
français Emmanuel Macron
ukrainienne
ukrainien la France se tient à vos côtés
à la solidarité à la victoire et à la
paix
Alice le Parlement est illuminé pour un
hommage silencieux
atmosphère bien différente à Londres ou
la foule se rassemblent à Trafalgar
Square pour une série de concerts et de
discours l'actrice britannique est
l'admirone récite un poème avant que
djamala vainqueur ukrainienne de
l'Eurovision en 2016 monte sur scène la
chanteuse est originaire de Crimée la
péninsule annexée par la Russie en 2014
pour nos droits à vivre chez nous au
21ème siècle nous nous battons pour
parler notre langue pour notre liberté
quelques heures plus tard à New York une
veillée aux bougies a lieu devant le
consulat russe drapeau ukrainien et
pancarte anti-putine ils sont brandis
en temps de guerre au moment horrible où
l'ennemi attaque nous démontrons que
nous pouvons oublier nos différences et
nous rassembler
parmi les manifestants des membres des
communautés ukrainiennes et russes comme
un message d'unité en temps de guerre